(comic zoom)
(comic snap)
- And long before social
let us flex on each other,
we did my the things we
wore, by the things we drove,
but the stories we told at the PTA.
Most, most people continued
to parent their children
based on what they think
other people think of them,
not by listening to their actual children.
(smooth R&B music)
(hollering)
You've got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(snapping)
I'm unbelievably humbled to
be speaking at this event,
just what an extraordinary
collection of people,
and I hope I get to
say hello to all of you
before I get out of here.
What I'm about to talk about
is predicated on the fact that
over the last three to four years,
off of a pretty sizable base of followers,
engagers on social, my
awareness grew exponentially
over platforms that skewed younger,
and as my attention on
Instagram and YouTube
grew aggressively over these 36 months,
what ended up happening
was a lot of the people
I was interacting with got younger,
and younger, and younger.
What I want to talk about today
is predicated on me reading
hundreds of thousands of direct messages
over the last three years.
What I want to talk about
today is not predicated on
my opinion, it's an
observation from one person,
one man's point of view.
It's also the observation of somebody
who is so deeply grateful
for the remarkable way
that I feel that my mother
parented me, and my father,
and the circumstances of being
an immigrant born in Belarus
coming to United States and
going through that struggle.
I believe that so much of
what every single person
in this audience cares deeply
about trying to affect,
and so many of the characteristics
that we are passionate
about, whether it's empathy,
or kindness, or gratitude, needs to have
a remarkable conversation
with ourselves around a word
called entitlement.
Entitlement is not privilege.
Entitlement is a very
important word for all of us,
because it is foundational
in the starting point
to all the other things
we've been talking about
over the last two days.
Entitlement is also
gonna be very difficult
for all of us to talk about in this room
because it means we have
to look at ourselves,
not look at the people
that we're imposing it on.
Over the last three years,
I have received hundreds
of thousands of messages
from 15-25 year olds
telling me variations of
stories of how much they love
and appreciate their parents
deeply, but deep down,
they resent them and, or hate them so much
because while they continue
to take their Unlimited Uber
from their parents, while
they continue to take
a brand new BMW on their 17th birthday,
while they continue to be thrilled
that their parents bought
them their first apartment
in New York City, or much smaller things,
like a first class plane ticket,
or something of that
degree, they inherently
deeply understand that
they are a zoo animal,
and are completely unprepared
to actually live in the world.
This is very difficult,
because so many, like myself,
come from places where
you start with nothing.
Half this audience came
from the fucking dirt,
the others had parents
or grandparents that did.
This is deep within us that
once you tasted garbage,
you have no interest in
letting your children taste it.
This is not judgment.
You're looking at a man
whose run two companies now,
and the number one vulnerability I've had
running these two companies successfully
is I personally created
too much entitlement
with my organizations,
because I don't like conflict,
I struggle with radical candor.
I'm a tough guy on fucking Instagram,
but in real life, I just
want to take all the pressure
and do it myself, and put
everybody in a happy place,
'cause happiness deploys better success
until it over corrects.
We have a whole culture that
is disproportionally judging
the youth, literally judging the youth
that they fucking parented.
My friends, for us to look
at this and understand
what's actually happening,
we have to understand
that so many in today's
society, and long before social
let us flex on each other,
we did it by the things
we wore, by the things we drove,
by the stories we told at the PTA.
Most, most people continue
to parent their children
based on what they think
other people think of them,
not by listening to their actual children.
This is a very important conversation.
We cannot get to the path
of all the other talks
that we've been listening to without
eliminating entitlement.
It is very difficult to
be empathetic or grateful
without eliminating entitlement.
We must put accountability on a pedestal.
We must destroy eighth place trophies.
That doesn't mean that
we don't admire effort,
but results fucking matter in life.
My mother gave me so
much fucking self esteem
that it makes some people not like me.
However, she equaled
that with uncomfortable
amounts of accountability.
When I went 0-4 in a baseball game,
and struck out four times,
it wasn't the sun's fault,
it wasn't my coach's fault.
She looked me in the face and
said, "You fucking sucked."
(audience laughing)
It didn't taste great,
it must've not been fun
for her to deliver, but
my deep, deep happiness
is predicated on her sucking
out every piece of entitlement
out of my body.
My deep capacity to be
empathetic and grateful,
which transforms in what most people see
is somebody who markets, but
in the way I navigate my life,
and the way I market to the end consumer,
my unbelievable opportunity to speak
in front of this crowd today,
is predicated on listening.
I talk, you listen to my podcast,
I interrupt every single
person that is on my show
because I've already heard what they said,
and I just want to move it
along, and we don't fucking edit.
It seems mean, it seems audacious,
it's deeply based on listening.
We have to start the process
of listening to the youth.
They're telling us the answers,
you just care what your
neighbor thinks about your kid,
you just care about what your
mother thinks about your kid,
sister thinks about your kid.
You need to start listening to your kid.
When this little hub-bub that popped up
about USC and other colleges,
this was no surprise to me,
there was no shock behind this.
We are a mass society
predicated on overreacting
to other people's judgment.
We are awfully good at judging,
we are awfully good at judging.
We have to start the
conversation around entitlement.
Entitlement's a tricky
one, it's a tricky one,
because it's not a lot of fun for people
that are trying to do
good to really look at it.
There's a whole lot of people
that clap for Greta's talk,
and then act a different way the next day.
We all know that.
The hypocrisy is fucking heavy.
Some things are really lofty.
It's hard to fucking boil
the ocean, but the truth is
you can absolutely start with yourself,
and let me promise you the
deep happiness in perpetuity
that you will have if
you start with your child
will change the course of your life.
I've seen this up close with my siblings,
I've seen this through the
eyes of hundreds of thousands
of people who I've talked to yesterday.
The resentment is palpable.
More importantly, they genuinely believe
that you do not believe in them
because you're subsidizing their behavior.
Fake environments were
the seed that lead us
to the uncomfortable place were in,
predicated on an enormous
amount of money and happiness
in the macro over the last 70 years.
And much like in out venture community
where people no longer
actually build businesses,
but they're building
financial arbitrage machines
to raise capital and
spend zero fucking time
caring about their consumer,
and 100% of their time
caring about venture
capitalists and press.
We equally have a community of parents
worried about what other people think
instead of how their kids feel.
It is also why the marketing
world is massively audacious.
We are entitled to think
somebody wants to watch
our bullshit video just
'cause we fucking made it.
We have to have a much,
much deeper conversation
about entitlement, and when we do,
all the other beautiful
words that have been spoken
in the last two days will
start to fall into place.
Thank you.
(audience applause)